On your left
so when they needed us we could fight
the battles
that they never could
Welcome back everyone i've gotten a lot
of requests to do a new video for marvel
and black panther i wanted to wait a
little while to talk about the future of
the black panther movies in black
panther 2 after it had been announced
that chadwick boseman passed away just
to pay him
the proper respect and honor his life i
posted a couple tribute videos and a lot
of you had been asking me black panther
2 questions what marvel is going to do
given how surprised and shocked everyone
was
with what happened so i'll explain what
they're doing right now
and on the other side of that i'll
explain what marvel is definitely not
going to do because there's been all
kinds of speculation in the past week
just given how serious this has all been
may he rest in power but the black
panther character in the black panther
franchise was very
important to chadwick bosemans in real
life so i'll address
how marvel is going to handle that going
forward but the big stuff if you didn't
hear the news last week
ryan coogler the director of the black
panther movies and someone who was
personally very close to chadwick
boseman and kevin feige both issued very
respectful very touching statements
honoring chadwick boseman's life and
accomplishments
not just what he did in the marvel
movies but what he did in real life in
his other work
if you haven't seen chadwick boseman's
other non-marvel movies he's fantastic
in everything that he does so be sure to
check those out
he's played many iconic fictional and
real world historical heroes
but while they were doing that last week
they also revealed that they personally
did not know about his condition
he had chosen to keep that secret from
most of the people he had worked with
the past couple of years since he found
out he had been diagnosed with stage
three cancer in 2016
that was around the time the captain
america civil war was happening right
after he had just started to play black
panther
he took it all like a champ he spent all
of his time between all these movies
undergoing intensive
cancer treatments and surgeries and when
you re-watch him during the black
panther movie avengers infinity war
avengers end game he looks amazing you
wouldn't think that anything was wrong
with him just to see him like that
but this past year his condition took a
turn for the worst and he still did
appear in a recent spike lee movie
earlier this year
but when he posted a video of himself
looking extremely thin
it was clear that something was not
right but here's the thing his family
said that even just a week before he
passed away
he was convinced that he was going to
beat cancer
and be able to start production on black
panther 2 in the spring next year
he was convinced that he'd be able to
gain all that weight back and get in
shape and time to start the movie
they said he was so optimistic that it
was going to be another amazing movie
just like the first black panther movie
which is inspiring
so as a result of that though both ryan
coogler who's still
riding black panther 2 right now and
kevin feige's people at marvel
didn't have any kind of alternative plan
for black panther 2 in place they were
also expecting chadwick boseman to come
back as t'challa and hit another home
run again for the sequel
so one of the first things i saw a lot
of you asking questions about on my
tribute video
last week was whether or not marvel was
planning on canceling the black panther
2 movie and just not doing it at all
and right now i can say that's not going
to happen for a number of reasons
the first one and probably the biggest
one being the chadwick boseman himself
said that when he first took the role as
black panther he just thought it'd be a
cool character
and he'd enjoy working with marvel just
like he enjoys working with all of his
collaborators on other movies that he
does
at least at first he wasn't really
thinking about what black panther the
character meant to people all over the
world or what it could mean
then when they were getting ready to
release the movie and it turned into
this big
cultural phenomenon it really hit him
and he recognized the deeper meaning
behind what they were doing and how
important it was
this is actually a clip of him getting
really choked up talking about it
working with little kids who themselves
were suffering from cancer
he did a lot of cancer charities so he
got to meet a lot of these children who
were looking forward to the black
panther movie coming out and it meant
the world to them
throughout our filming i was
communicating with them
um knowing that they were both terminal
and and what they said to me is
and their parents said they just they're
trying to hold on
till this movie comes
and i
to a certain degree you hear them say
that and you're like
like wow that's
like i got to get up and i got to get up
and go to the gym
i got to get up and go to work um you
know
i got to learn these lines i got to work
on this accident uh
you know seeing how devoted all of my
castmates are
and knowing that that that that will be
something meaningful
to them but it's to a certain degree
it's a humbling experience because
you're like this can't mean that much to
them
you know but seeing how
the world has taken us on seeing how
the movement is how it's taking on a
life of its own
i realized that they anticipated
something great and um
i think back now to a kid and just
you know uh waiting for christmas to
come waiting for my birthday to come
waiting for a toy that was going to that
i was going to get a chance to
experience or a video game
i did live life waiting for those
moments
and so it put me back in the mind of
being a kid
just just to experience those two little
boys
anticipation of this movie and when i
found out that they
yeah it's it's it means a lot
so watching him get choked up there you
also have to remember that while he was
doing this working with those little
kids who were themselves
suffering from cancer he was also
suffering from stage three cancer
so marvel recognizes how much the black
panther franchise means to everyone and
how much it meant to chadwick boseman
they're not going to end that chadwick
boseman wouldn't want them to stop
making black panther movies but
everything that they've said and that
ryan coogler has said
since he passed away has been that they
want to be as respectful as possible
and honor his memory the best way that
they can so that's why marvel is not
going to recast the t'challa black
panther character
chadwick boseman will always be the
t'challa of the mcu the same way that
robert downey jr will always be the tony
stark of the mcu
you probably see where i'm going with
this mantles are passed down in the
comics
wholesale identities are not the clear
path forward is to pass the mantle of
black panther in the throne of wakanda
to t'challa's heir apparent
shuri is the heir apparent also in real
life marvel just recently made all the
black panther comics where shuri takes
the mantle of black panther
free for download but what is that story
and how do they address
chadobic boseman passing away t'challa
passing away
so soon after avengers end game when
they all just came back
snapped back by the hulk's infinity
gauntlet you don't send a champ and a
king like black panther out
with a couple lines of dialogue it has
to be something epic it has to have deep
ramifications to the universe and if
we're talking about the mcu
the future marvel movies the other
characters in the other movies like thor
the other surviving avengers have to
feel the weight of it
the two most common ways that you do
this are one with a new big bad which is
the more obvious choice
and one of the more respectful but epic
ways to do that would be to tie it to
the debut of a major new x-men or
fantastic four villain like namor or
doctor doom
early speculation but t'challa winds up
passing away at the beginning of black
panther 2 or preceding the events of the
movie
defending wakanda from an attack from
one of these new villains
the second way that you can address his
passing is the avatar the last airbender
way
if you haven't seen that series it's one
of the best series of all time it's on
netflix please go watch it
but after the events of avatar the last
airbender aang wound up having a family
with katara but died at the relatively
young age of
66 but because he'd been stuck in the
ice for a hundred years
using the avatar state to survive he was
really about 166 years old when he died
and the real reason why he passed away
wasn't because of the big battle
it was just because of the physical
stress of being in the avatar state for
such a long period of time
shortening his lifespan so if there were
ever an acceptable time to use old
footage of chadwick boseman t'challa
or reworking him to put him back in the
movie it would be to have
shuri speak to him albeit briefly inside
the spirit world the way that he spoke
to his father king tachaka after he had
passed away
but one of the most important lines of
dialogue that he has in any of the
marvel movies is in captain america
civil war after his father dies and this
is very timely and relevant
he says that death is not the end in
their culture it's more of a stepping
off point
but then what is the actual story of the
black panther 2 movie if shuri is taking
the mantle and a major new x-men or
fantastic four villain
is responsible for his death well the
basic premise of the movie would be
mostly how shuri and the rest of the
marvel characters deal with the tragedy
of his death
and shuri learning what it means to be
the black panther and what it means to
be queen of wakanda
so you're introducing all this new mcu
x-men fantastic four canon
and you're also spinning on some of the
things that they did during the first
film
with shuri's character and like i said
they've actually just done a version of
this in another marvel movie
if it wasn't clear shuri in the mcu is
the exact same
age as peter parker spider-man the same
thing just happened to him in spider-man
far from home
he had to deal with the death of iron
man and iron man effectively passed the
mantle to him
via the glasses but everyone let me know
in the comments how do you want marvel
to handle
chadwick boseman's passing during black
panther 2.
and of course there would be an epic
stan lee tribute to him at the beginning
and the end of the movie during the
credits
the stanley opening credits were kind of
comedic because stanley's cameos were
all very comedic the one that they would
do for chadwick boseman
would be much more serious and in the
tone of a black panther character
everyone be sure to pay him tribute in
the comments may he rest in power
you can click here for both of my
chadwick boseman tribute videos too
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!